I started my career as a cinematographer
so obviously the look of the film is
important to me there's no greater
canvas for that look than I was
I think transcendence and IMAX are a
very good match IMAX is the one true
immersive format it's not only having
the screen filler peripheral vision but
having the sound jump off 20 or 30 feet
from the screen it engulfs you in the
experience once online a sentient
machine will quickly overcome the limits
of biology while it was a large project
for a first-time director it was too
intriguing for me to pass up its
analytical power will be greater than
the collective intelligence of every
person in the history of the world
I call it transcendence she thought it
was very unique I thought it was a very
original concept for a film and then
also thought it was very current there
are a couple of scenes in particular
take advantage of the immersive quality
of the IMAX image as well as the sound
there's one segment where it's a journey
through the internet it's a fantastic
visual moment and the sound design is
very carefully put together and that's a
particular moment that I loved seeing
when I saw the IMAX version
and anything you do you draw on all your
life experience I worked as a camera
operator for Robert Altman and seven
films for Christopher Nolan that becomes
what you draw from I think that the look
of a movie there's an evolution all the
elements have to come together and
combine to create the look of a pill
IMAX is a wonderful way to be able to
tell a visual story
as a director I'd love to continue
working in the largest possible format
and on the largest canvas
I think people are gonna be blown away
when they get a chance to see
transcendence in IMAX
it's really the format that the film is
designed to be seen